in this video you're gonna learn how to
graph the sine and cosine graphs as well
as graphing sine and cosine when they're
transformed we're going to be working
with this general formula right here
where H is the horizontal shift K is the
vertical shift B is related to the
period through this formula two pi
divided by B and then a is going to be
our amplitude or our vertical stretch or
compress so let's start off by talking
about how do you graph the basic sine
and cosine graph well if you go to the
unit circle which you probably already
learned about previously if not check
out my mastering the unit circle video
when we think about the unit circle when
we're talking about sine what we do is
we go to the angle for example zero
radians and we say what's the sine of
zero radians well it's going to be the
y-coordinate so you can see at zero sine
is going to be equal to zero at PI over
2 or 90 degrees you can see that the
sine the Y value is going to be one so
at PI over two let's put a point at one
and then at PI 180 degrees you can see
that the Y value is going to be zero so
that's going to be right there and then
at 3 PI over 2 which is right here you
can see the sine value is negative one
and then at two pi you're back to zero
and what happens is that this graph just
repeats like this it's like an s-shaped
forever and ever so it's good to have a
basic understanding and a kind of a
memorization of what the basic shape of
the sine graph looks like what I like to
think of is it starts at the midline it
goes to the maximum back to the midline
minimum back to the midline now let's
look at cosine same idea when you work
with cosine you're going to look at the
x coordinates okay so cosine of zero
radians is going to be one so we
actually start up here at one at PI over
2 or 90 you can see that cosine is going
to be 0 at PI you can see that cosine is
negative 1 at 3 PI over 2 cosine is
going to be 0 and at 2 pi you're back to
1 and so you can see the basic shape of
the cosine graph looks something like
that and I like to think of it as
starting at the maximum then going to
the midline a minimum midline back to
the maximum so again you want to
memorize the basic shape for cosine
it'll make it easier when we go into
these more challenging examples we're
gonna be doing next so first let's start
off kind of a Bay
SiC one and then we'll get more
challenging as we go see if you can
graph y equals two sine one-half X okay
so the way I would approach this is I
would say okay there's a number that
comes in front of the sine or the cosine
that's involved with the vertical
stretch or shrink if it's greater than
one it's going to be a stretch if it's
between zero and one it's gonna be a
shrink this is what we call our
amplitude and when you think of
amplitude you can think of these as like
waves and it's like how high are the
waves from that midline okay and so what
you can do here is you can see that
they're going to be too high okay and so
what's gonna happen is gonna be a
vertical stretch of the sine graph by -
okay you're multiplying all the Y values
by two but what is this 1/2 do well the
1/2 is related to the period through
this formula two pi divided by B so you
can see if we were to put 1/2 in here 2
pi divided by 1/2 well when you divide
it's like multiplying by the reciprocal
so it's really like multiplying by the
reciprocal of 1/2 which is 2 and you can
see that's going to come out to a period
of 4 pi so what I like to do next is and
I like to take that 4 pi excuse me and
divide it by 4 because that's going to
give us the scale on the horizontal axis
so 4 pi divided by 4 gives us 1 pi so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
count by PI so this is gonna be 1 PI 2
pi 3 PI 4 PI just like you see over here
where we divide it up into quarters 1 2
3 4 just like the quadrants e 1 2 ok
dividing up into fourths again we know
that sine starts at the midline so right
here it goes up to the maximum that's to
back to the midline down to the minimum
that's here at negative 2 back to the
midline and that's going to give us our
basic you know shape of our sine graph
the only difference is it's been
stretched by 2 in the vertical direction
it's also been stretched in the
horizontal direction by 2 and again we
figured that out because the 1/2 here
group of the X has the opposite effect
on the graph and actually instead of
looks like you're dividing by 2 it's
actually multiplying the X values by 2
but a lot of students like to do is just
use this formula 2 PI over B to find the
new period again the periods how long it
takes for to complete one cycle before
it repeats then divide it by 4
or multiply by 1/4 to get the scale like
what's your counting by each of those
quarters okay let's look at another
example see if you can do number 4 here
we've got y equals negative cosine of 2
times the quantity X minus PI over 4
okay a little bit more challenging here
what do you think the negative does to
the graph well the negative is going to
make all the Y values the opposite sign
so it's going to actually reflect it
over the x-axis okay now when you talk
about the amplitude this number here
that comes in front of the sign of the
cosine the amplitude is always positive
so if your teacher says what's the
amplitude here you would say the
amplitude is 1 here you'd say the
amplitudes 2 it's always positive this
negative is just reflecting it okay now
let's go to the period so we're gonna
use this formula again 2 pi divided by B
B as 2 so that means that period is
going to be 2 pi divided by 2 which is
pi okay and so then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to figure out the scale by
multiplying this by 1/4 or dividing by 4
so that's going to be pi divided by 4 2
pi divided by 4 which is PI over 2 3 PI
over 4 and then 4 PI over 4 which is pi
so we're always dividing up into fourths
but now we're working with cosine and
when we think about cosine we know that
cosine normally starts at the maximum
value right but because it's being
reflected because of this negative it's
gonna go stout and start down here at
the minimum value right but what about
this PI over 4 well the PI over 4 okay
when it's group with the X like this
it's shifting it in the horizontal
direction left and right but this
actually has the opposite effect so the
minus PI over 4 is actually gonna pick
up the graph and shift it to the right
PI over 4 what I like to do is I like to
draw like an open circle okay and I'm
gonna think of this as my new origin so
if I wanted to I could kind of drawing
like a dotted line this is kind of like
my new y-axis this is kind of like you
know my x-axis and this is like my
origin or my starting point so now that
I've taken the shift into account all I
have to do now is graph my basic cosine
graph but keep in mind that it's
reflected so it's going to start down
here so it's going to start over here at
negative 1 then it's going to go back to
the midline up to the maximum positive 1
back to the midline
then over here back to the minimum this
is going to be at 5 PI over 4 and now if
we draw our graph we've got it now you
can draw more points and continue on
that graph and both directions but this
is one period or one cycle let's do a
couple more examples ok see if you can
do number five we've got y equals 3 sine
x minus 3 how would you graph that one
well the first thing I want you to
notice is is this 3 group with this X
well if it was in parenthesis like you
see here then it would be what we call a
phase shift left and right okay but
because the 3 is an i group with the X
this tells us that it's a vertical shift
up and down the minus 3 is going to
shift it down 3 if it was plus 3 which
shifted up 3 this K value has the same
effect as the sine whereas the one group
with the X remember that has the
opposite effect so here what I like to
do because it's minus 3 shifted down 3
as I like to go down 3 and I like to
draw like a dashed or dotted line I'm
going to think of this as our new x axis
okay
it's not shifting left or right so I'm
gonna think of this point right here at
negative 3 as our new origin or our new
starting point now all I have to do is
focus on what's left which is y equals 3
sine of X and we know the 3 already is
the amplitude that's the vertical
stretch is stretching it by 3 in the Y
direction and all we have to do now if
we are familiar with our sine graph is
graph the sine graph but instead of
going up to 1 we're gonna go up to 3
instead of going down to negative 1
we're gonna go down to negative 3 okay
so let's go ahead and do that so it
starts at the midline ok for sine cosine
remember starts at the maximum then
we're gonna go up to the maximum ok
which is going to be here at 0k I went
up 3 then we're back to the midline then
we're down to the minimum which is going
to be 3 below that midline and then
we're back to the midline ok now the
only thing that I didn't put in this yet
are the scale the X values here so we
want to do is we want to look at the
number that comes in front of X that's
one we want to use the form of the 2 pi
divided by B that B is 1 so 2 pi divided
by 1 is 2 pi okay so that's going to be
our period and then we want to divide
that by 4 or
multiply by 1/4 and that's going to give
us a scale of PI over 2 once we reduced
so we're counting here by PI over 2 to
PI over 2 which is pi 3 PI over 2 4 PI
over 2 which is 2 pi and that gives us
our scale okay let's go to number 6 now
see if you can do this one y equals
cosine PI over 4 times the quantity X
plus 2 plus 1 okay so what do you think
on this one well the first thing I like
to do and I didn't do it on this one but
what I like to do first is I like to
figure out what the period is so I can
figure out the scale is on our x-axis so
let's do that first we've got period
equals 2 pi divided by PI over 4 right
that's our B value when we divide by a
fraction it's like multiplying by the
reciprocal so this is really like 2 pi
times 4 over pi 2 pi is like 2 pi over 1
see how the PI's cancel and 2 times 4
gives us a period of 8 so let's go to
our x-axis here let's call this 8 if we
divide this by 4 cause remember we're
dividing up into 4 pieces this is going
to give us a scale of 2 so it's gonna go
to 4 6 8
okay so I just keep adding 2 each time
now what I like to do is I like to take
the shift into a cow so this is the
phase shift left and right this is our
vertical shift up and down remember the
one group with the X has the opposite
effect so the +2 is actually going to
shift it to the left 2 and the +1 is
going to shift it up 1 so what we're
gonna think of is going left 2 up 1 this
is gonna be like our new starting point
right here our new origin I like to draw
in like a dashed or dotted line okay to
represent the x axis you can do the same
thing with the the y axis so this is
like our new origin now all we have to
do is graph our cosine graph it has an
amplitude of 1 see how there's nothing
in front of the cosine that's understood
to be 1 cosine and we know that the
cosine starts here at the maximum at the
high point so in this case our high
point is going to be at 1 because the
amplitude is 1 so it's gonna start here
at 1 it goes back to the midline which
is going to be right here
and then it goes down to the minimum
back to the midline and then back to the
maximum which is here at 1 so we've got
our graph looks something like
and you can keep repeating etc let's do
one last example that involves all these
different transformations so you can get
a really good grasp on this okay see if
we can do this one this is a real
challenging example here 1/2 sine of the
quantity 3x plus pi minus 2 it's got a
little bit of everything and the first
thing I like to do is to find that
period and that X scale so what's
interesting about this problem though is
you see how that this isn't in this form
where it's like X plus something or X
minus something there's at 3 in front of
the X what we want to do is we want to
factor out that 3 to put it into this
form it's easier to identify the phase
shift so let's go ahead and do that so
I'm gonna factor out the 3 which that's
going to leave us with PI over 3 inside
of the parenthesis so what I did is I I
factored out the 3 or you know divided
out the 3 you can see if you double
check by distributing you get back to 3x
plus pi which is what we have here so
now you can see that that B value is 3
and our period is gonna be 2 pi divided
by 3 okay now if we multiply that by 1/4
to find our scale what we're counting by
that's going to give us 2 PI over 12
which reduces down to PI over 6
ok so let's go ahead and put 2 PI over 3
here divide that into four pieces of
just PI over 6 so this is 1 PI over 6 2
PI over 6 you can reduce that to PI over
3 3 PI over 6 which is PI over 2 4 PI
over 6 which is 2 PI over 3 if you go
the other direction this would be like a
negative PI over 6 a negative 2 PI over
6 which is a negative PI over 3 if you
reduce now what we want to do is we want
to take into account the phase shift and
the vertical shift so the plus PI over 3
remember the one group with the ax has
the opposite effect this is actually
going to shift it left PI over 3 so
because our scales PI over 6 we have to
shift two steps to the left so that's
gonna be PI over 3 negative PI over 3
over here the -2 has the same effect
it's going to shift down 2 so I'm going
to do here is I'm going to shift left PI
over 3 down 2 we're gonna think of this
is our new origin and you can draw in
like a a new axis right here through
this point
and we're going to think of this as a
starting point or origin now we're gonna
graph our sign graph but you can see the
one half is our amplitude this is like a
vertical shrink by 1/2 it's gonna have
the same basic shape as a graph of sine
here just compressed by 1/2 in the
vertical direction so we're gonna do is
going to start here we're going to go up
to the maximum which is going to be 1/2
above our midline back to the midline
we're going to go a half below that
midline okay then we're to go back to
the midline and it just repeats so you
can keep you know going and making more
cycles but that's going to be your basic
graph one period if you want to learn
more about graphing sine and cosine as
well as graphing tangent cotangent
secant and cosecant follow me over to
that video right there we'll dive more
into the other trigonometric functions
and how to graph them I'll see you in
that video